first up she is the first female combat
veteran running to be president in
United States and Hawaii's rep from the
second congressional district there
Tulsi Gabbard okay well I love you and I
love Hawaii I thought you did quite well
thank you I did I did we're gonna
eliminate some people tonight and you're
not one of them I want you to stick
around no what do you think of the
debates in general how do you think the
party in general looked look I think it
is it's tough when you've got 60 seconds
to say well how are you gonna solve
climate change yeah how are you gonna
you know deal with the the national
security threats that we face how are
you gonna deal with this threat of
nuclear war that we face so you know I
think the format is challenging but I
think all of this really comes down to
who can best defeat Donald Trump but
that those issues didn't come up a lot
that's a problem yeah right that is the
problem right well you know if I was
just passing viewer yeah it was like
checking over the field chopping my
first look at a lot of these people I
would have thought well the Democrats
really really really really really
really care about illegal immigrants
they also care somewhat about health
care and energy and the environment
mostly about how they affect illegal
immigrants
at one point last night they were asked
or was it your night to raise your hand
if you think that illegal immigrants
should get free health care and they all
raise their hand and this was the New
York Post headline today who wants to
lose the election what do you think
about that look I saw an interview that
you did recently talking specifically
about how the media is driving for
profits and ratings and divisive nasai
looking at what are the real issues that
the American people are struggling with
how are we as candidates running for
president seeking to solve those those
challenges but ultimately I think what
all of this comes down to is that
ultimate question is who is the best
candidate to defeat Donald Trump that's
our objective in November of 2020 the
people on this stage if they seem to be
playing to the Twitter rowdy yeah that
2% one thing I like about you is having
been to war I feel like your attitude
about the Twitter people is like I've
been to war so like I could give a [ __ ]
what you people say about me much in
yeah
it's true though I mean this this is
really about leadership or the lack
thereof and we have too many politicians
who you know put their finger up to the
Twitter wind and see which way it's
blowing and then respond or change their
position or whatever the case may be
rather than actually leading looking at
these issues based on their merit on
their substance saying what is in the
best interests of the American people
that that's what I try to do and and
honestly people have a hard time
figuring me out because I don't play
those games right I don't fit in those
boxes
I mean politicians have always put their
finger to the wind that's okay to some
point you're supposed to represent to a
degree to people who voted for you but
put your finger up to the 98% yeah not
the 2% if you're gonna put your finger
in the wind don't do it to the 2% wind
is my request okay
so what do you think of who this all got
buried because of the debates yeah Trump
is in Japan he met with Putin loved it
of course his his spirit animal
I mean he was joking about the fact that
Putin meddled in our election some
reporter said are you gonna tell
President Putin not to meddle in the
election he made a joke out of it
he made a joke out of the fact he said
something about reporters fake news we
have to deal with that you're lucky in
Russia you don't
which you know Putin is killed by some
accounts over 20 journalists so get it
ha ha I mean this is just beyond the
pale yeah yeah I mean we have to take
seriously the security of our elections
because of the vulnerabilities that
exists still now that really have the
ability to undermine our democracy
there's a hacking conference that's held
every year in Las Vegas where I think a
14 or 15 year old girl from Florida
hacked into a replica of Florida's
election system in less than 15 minutes
there are too many states in this
country who still don't use any type of
paper ballot or have any paper record of
the votes that are cast so when you
think about whether it's a foreign
country or a rogue actor or a high
school student who's going in with the
intent of manipulating the outcome of
the votes that we cast that is the true
danger to our democracy and to our
elections I've introduced legislation
called the securing America's Elections
Act that would very simply solve that
make sure that there's either a paper
ballot or if you're using a machine have
a voter verified paper backup so that no
matter what happens no matter who tries
to interfere in our elections we have
the ability to audit that vote that are
well the problem is that whether it's
Republicans and leadership or Democrats
and leadership they're talking about how
much they care about the security of our
elections but they've failed to do
anything about it they've failed to pass
my legislation or other people who've
introduced similar pieces of legislation
it's all talk it's not actually how the
Republicans can see a
see a display like that of Trump with
Putin he's done this before but you know
with the American flag pin yeah I think
you got to take that pin off if you're
okay with that look it get getting back
to what our mission is what our focus is
is putting the interests of the American
people above all else and that is the
problem with Washington whether it's one
party or the other party they'll go
after the other party yeah well they
turn our guide to the problems in their
own rather than putting the key
recognize one place where you're fairly
similar to Trump is you're a
non-interventionist I mean you see this
with Iran lately he's he's kind of torn
you know part of him of course always
wants to strike back but he has kind of
staked his claim Foreign Affairs wise on
being the guy who does not want us to
get into more Wars more regime regime
change worse you're on that same page he
talked a lot about that in his 2016
campaign but through his administration
and through his presidency we've seen
something very different I think that's
why a lot of folks who voted for him are
they feel very betrayed you mentioned
Iran he says he doesn't want to go to
war with Iran but if you look at the
actions that he and his administration
have taken and maybe he's not aware of
it maybe these guys are doing on their
own John Boehner Mike Pompeo and others
but every single decision that they have
made towards Iran is laying the
groundwork for an eventual war but we're
not there yet and he could have done it
last week when they shot down the drone
and he said something which I think if
Obama said it we would have liked which
was hey we don't know who who made that
order
that's what Kennedy said in them yeah
Cuban Missile Crisis right it would be
rash really doesn't want to go to war
with Iran he's got to swallow his pride
and get back into the Iran nuclear what
was bribed that's not gonna happen no
because if he doesn't I mean if he
doesn't
John Bolton and Mike Pompeo and others I
mean they have they have literally laid
the dynamite and I know but use one
thing about him he's the boss yeah you
know he doesn't care what other people
say okay so where you want impeachment
impeachment is not gonna get rid of
Donald Trump no we've got understand
that first probably it's realistically
so you're ago no because I think it's
important that the American people are
the ones who decisively defeat Donald
Trump in 2020 that's the debate in your
party yeah good luck with the campaign
I'm glad you're out there together
you